hallo mein name ist luca nachdem ich vor
einer woche bereits auf einen typischen
tag im leben des reichsten mädchens der
welt reagiert habe schauen wir uns heute
mal einen typischen tag im leben des
schönsten mädchens der welt an man
könnte meinen dass schönheit nur im auge
des betrachters liegt ist ja auch so sie
zu messen ist daher eigentlich gar nicht
möglich denn jeder empfindet
unterschiedliche dinge als schönes ei
gucken was sind die normen mit dem
abständen der augen wie sollte der mund
irgendwie in relation hinsichtlich der
sprache werde auf jeden fall nicht der
schönste mensch der welt um so etwas
festzulegen gibt es
schönheitswettbewerbe wie etwa den miss
universe oder den miss world contest
kann mir jemand dieses miss universe
dinge erklären was ist denn wenn
beispielsweise auf dem mars einfach so
extrem geiler aliens chillen
[Musik]
geht man danach wäre die schönste frau
des universums aktuell die aus den
philippinen stammt catriona gray
ein paar sekunden später
ja
das ist mein fuß oder
im auge des betrachters jeder empfindet
andere dinge als schön und das ist
natürlich auch gut so und richtig und
wichtig allerdings mein geschmack ist
jetzt überhaupt nicht und miss universe
neben wettbewerben gibt es allerdings
auch seriöse versuche von
wissenschaftlern das schönste gesicht
nur mit hilfe von geometrie und zahlen
zu ermitteln
das meine ich die augen abstände
hinsichtlich der nase wäre ich auch der
letzte platz da stimmen unter dem namen
independent critics bewerten
verschiedene experten aus aller welt
jedes jahr millionen von einreichung am
ende wird eine liste der 100 schönsten
gesichter der welt veröffentlicht denn
man nach dieser litt
ja ich bin verliebt
wenn man nach dieser liste geht dass sie
das schönste mädchen der welt kühl am
plan
an
mich jetzt so sah die als kind aus was
ich falsch gemacht so sah ich als kind
aus dieser vergleicht uns mal
immer wenn ich mir diese videos angucken
sind mein selbstbewusstsein so aufhört
des erb kerns
auch letzte woche mit der mit kylie
jenner die jünger ist als ich aber eine
milliarde auf dem konto hat
ich sollte damit aufhören die erst 18
jährige trotz ihres jungen alters
bereits unglaubliche fünf jahre in folge
teil der renommierten leicester doch was
macht nur in ihrer jugend schon mal
selbst hält
können mal alle auf den kauf von ihr
gehen und sie fragen ob sie vielleicht
irgendwie mit mir ein eis essen gehen
will wenn das da ich denn jetzt schön
blond uhr ist französin kann ich auch
noch champignons champagner john payne
provence normandie die sich jetzt noch
nicht verliebt da dann weiß ich auch
nicht
genauer gesagt in paris
wer dort wohnt sie in einer eigenen
penthouse-wohnung erreicht weit entfernt
vom eiffelturm die wohnung ist noch
die sich nur hübsche
wohnung in paris von nur einem jahr
wohnte sie nämlich noch im anwesen ihrer
eltern in aix-en-provence einer kleinen
stadt im süden frankreichs
einer
statt
extrem klar wenn sie morgen
auftakt ist er los
[Musik]
so kannst du dich mich wie lange ried
ist selber als dj tätig und verdiente
damit auch bereits viel geld will hahn
und ihr freund beginnt den tag immer mit
einem guten frühstück das sind dumme
aussage immer wir geben die den tag mit
einem guten wollte sowie außerdem werde
ich es wahrscheinlich wirklich machen
morgens gibt es bei vielen nämlich immer
dasselbe waffeln mit puderzucker
wenn puderzucker
nicht sehr aus wie die mülltonne
nach einem guten frühstück kümmert sich
die französin erstmal um das wichtigste
ja aussehen stadt dabei jedoch auf viele
teure pflegeprodukte zu setzen sch wird
sie auf die wirkung von gewöhnlichem
wasser auf der haut
sympathisch
die kinder halten normalerweise gegen
das führte land dann anschließend zur
schule doch sie hat ein blick auf ihre
kindheit zeigt dass sie eigentlich schon
ihr ganzes leben lang gearbeitet hat das
hat auch mit ihrer familie zu tun als
ziel an 2001
die sehen sich ja so ähnlich
das ist ja geisteskrank was das für die
ähnlichkeit als patrick london über
professioneller fußballspieler und
spielte mehrere jahre lang und der
französischen liga bei olympique
marseille bei ihrer ersten modeschau
modelte sie bereits für designer jean
paul gaultier und entzückte dabei das
gesamte publikum dies mit ein paar
jahren ist jeder modenschauen gelaufen
da habe ich mir dann die hosen gibt es
war ja auch immer noch wie sie selbst
sagt wo eltern niemals dazu gezwungen
nachfahren abstieg auftritt hielt sie
immer größere modeljobs und so wurde es
für den alltag nach dem kindergarten mit
ihren eltern ins fotostudio zu fahren
ich komme die euch mal an
das soll jetzt überhaupt nicht hier pädo
mäßig klinge ich weiß nicht wie alt ihr
war aber man kann ja trotzdem sagen
lassen kinder einfach extrem hübsch
aussieht
ich könnt ihr den ganzen tag in die
augen schauen und ilanz bilderwand
gefragt und nach unten ab ich kann ich
kann dir nicht mehr in die augen schaue
ich bin verliebt das schönste mädchen
der welt war daraufhin gefragt wie nie
der renommierte star fotograf daniel
becker machte porträts von vielen als
sie erst sieben jahre alt war wie mode
zeit arbeitete mit ihr zusammen bekam
sogar ein schauspiel angebot
jeder noch geschauspielert
[Musik]
immer wieder muss sich jedoch auch nach
los angeles reisen um dort zu arbeiten
die kalifornische metropole ist
inzwischen schon fast ihre zweite heimat
geworden da sie nicht selten mehrere
monate am stück in der stadt lebt
mehrere monate am stück
juli
hat neben dem modeln viele andere
leidenschaften sie spielt sehr gerne und
gut klavier dass sie auch
leidenschaftliche schlagzeugerin sagt
allerdings nicht nur musikalische hobbys
um sondern betreibt auch sport immer
wieder gibt es in edelrestaurants ab und
zu recht hier aber auch einfaches fast
food am liebsten pizza
[Musik]
gera figur macht das allerdings nichts
aus denn trotz ihrer relativ ungesunden
ernährung ergattert sie weiterhin
regelmäßig
mir fehlen die worte mir fehlen die
worte ich weiß dass das alles jetzt hier
einfach nur oberflächlich ist ich habe
noch kein wort aus ihrem mund gehört ich
weiß nicht wie sie so drauf ist aber das
ist ja auch eine sehr oberflächliche und
da muss man einfach sagen wer die nicht
schön findet klar es liegt im auge des
betrachters aber verriet in einem
interview dass sie sich vor allem auch
an ihrem titel des schönsten mädchens
der welt sehr stören würde diese
bezeichnung führe laut ihr immer wieder
dazu dass sich leute über ihr aussehen
beschweren weil sie sie eigentlich gar
nicht attraktiv finden
immer wieder höre sie dass es viel
schönere mädchen gebe als sie selbst
dabei hat thailand selbst eigentlich nie
behauptet dass sie die schönste wäre es
halt auch wieder so dass dinge so etwas
einfach so gesagt bekommen und wurde von
der welt so angesehen und eine schönheit
ist halt wie ich schon gesagt habe liegt
im auge des betrachters und wenn man sie
nicht schön findet dann ist das halt so
aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
das nicht nur rosige seiten hat
allerdings ist das heutige video david
auch beendet das natürlich nicht in die
sonne richtiger tag im leben des
schönsten mädchen der welt was sie hier
dargestellt haben ja nicht nur gesagt
dass sie
allerdings über ihren tagesablauf heraus
wenn ich das heutige video allerdings
dennoch gefallen hat würde ich nicht
selbst solle bei einem daumen hoch von
euch unter dem video ihr freund schreibt
mir gerne mal und in die kommentare wie
ihr diesem thema findet ich werde mich
jetzt auf jeden fall nach frankreich
gegeben bevor ich das tue könnt ihr
allerdings hier auf den smiley
draufklicken da könnt ihr einen kanal
abonnieren dann verpasste diese
meisterwerke an videokunst demnächst
nicht mehr
also trägt gern drauf und hier jetzt ein
video verlinkt das ich soeben auf meinem
2 kanal hochgeladen habe da hab ich mich
auf das komplette gegenteil reagiert
nämlich auf richtig hässlich zeichnungen
die dann mit photoshop ins leben gerufen
wurde also klingt da gern raus